That's not fair. Every parent has heard that cry dozens, if not hundreds of times. From a very early age, we humans seem wired to notice when other people are getting more than we are and to complain about it loudly when they do. As adults, our sense of fairness and justice becomes broader and more nuanced. We care about equal pay for equal work, for example, or about which countries are right or wrong in global conflicts, even when those issues might not touch our lives directly. Questions such as these of fairness, justice, and morality might seem unique to humans, but research suggests that non-human animals notice inequality as well, and that by studying how they react to unfair situations, we can better understand how our human sense of justice evolved.
“这不公平。”每一位家长都听过这句话几十次，甚至几百次。从很小的时候起，人类似乎就天生会对别人比自己得到更多的情况保持敏感，并在发生时大声抱怨。作为成年人，我们的公平感和正义感变得更加宽广和细腻。例如，我们关心同工同酬，或者关心在全球冲突中哪些国家是对的，哪些是错的，即使这些问题可能并不直接影响我们的生活。关于公平、正义和道德的问题似乎是人类独有的，但研究表明，非人类动物也会注意到不平等，通过研究它们对不公平情况的反应，我们可以更好地理解人类的正义感是如何演化而来的。
So how do animals, from crows to chimpanzees, understand fairness? Do they get mad when they're treated unfairly? How can researchers tell? How much do different species differ? and how they react to inequality. What about individual animals? And what can we learn from studying these questions about why humans care so much about equality and fairness and about how we cooperate and compete with one another? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology,
那么，从乌鸦到黑猩猩，动物是如何理解公平的呢？当它们受到不公平对待时会生气吗？研究人员是如何判断的？不同物种在对不平等的反应上有多大差异？个体动物的情况又如何？通过研究这些问题，我们能学到什么关于人类为何如此看重平等与公平，以及我们如何相互合作与竞争的知识？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，
the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Sarah Brosnan, a distinguished university professor in the departments of psychologists, and philosophy, and the Neuroscience Institute at Georgia State University, where she also directs the comparative economics and behavioral sciences lab. She and her colleagues
这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。今天的嘉宾是莎拉·布罗斯南博士，她是乔治亚州立大学心理学系、哲学系和神经科学研究所的杰出大学教授，同时还负责指导比较经济学和行为科学实验室。她和她的同事们
studied decision-making, cooperation, and fairness in non-human primates, such as chimpanzees and monkeys, in order to better understand how these qualities evolved in humans. Her research has been funded by the National Science Foundation and National Institutes of Health, among others. She's published more than 150 scientific papers and book chapters and has won numerous awards for her mentoring and research. Her TED talk on why monkeys and humans are wired for fairness has been viewed nearly 1.5 million times. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Braslin. It's a real pleasure to be here. Thanks, Kim. Let's start with how you got into this research. You have a funny story about the first time you thought, hmm, maybe animals care about fairness. Can you tell
研究了非人类灵长类动物（如黑猩猩和猴子）的决策、合作和公平性，以更好地理解这些品质在人类中是如何演化的。她的研究得到了美国国家科学基金会和美国国立卫生研究院等机构的资助。她发表了150多篇科学论文和书籍章节，并因其指导和研究工作获得了无数奖项。她关于“为什么猴子和人类天生追求公平”的TED演讲观看次数已接近150万次。感谢您今天参加我们的节目，布罗斯南博士。很高兴来到这里。谢谢你，金。让我们从你是如何开始这项研究的谈起。你有一个关于你第一次想到“嗯，也许动物也关心公平”的有趣故事。你能告诉
us about that moment that first sparked your interest in this research? Absolutely. I was a first-year grad student, and one of the things that I had always been told by my advisor, Franz de Wall, was that you really get the best questions about the animals from watching the animals. So I spent a lot of time outside my first year in grad school watching our groups of capuchin monkeys interact with one another. And one afternoon, I was out feeding one of the groups, peanuts, and they really like peanuts. And of course, what's that means is that the more dominant animals come up and try to get all of the peanuts and the more subordinate animals get left out. So what you do is you do this little trick thing where you hold
我们那个最初激发你对这项研究产生兴趣的时刻吗？当然。我当时是一名一年级的研究生，我的导师弗兰斯·德·瓦尔一直告诉我的一件事是，你真正能从动物身上得到最好的问题，就是通过观察动物。所以我研究生一年级时花了很多时间在户外观察我们的卷尾猴群体之间的互动。一天下午，我正在给其中一个群体喂花生，它们真的很喜欢花生。当然，这意味着更占优势的动物会过来试图抢走所有的花生，而处于从属地位的动物则会被冷落。所以你所做的就是玩一个小把戏，你手里拿着
peanuts in both hands and you try to tempt the dominant animal over to one side while you are surreptitiously sneaking peanuts to the more subordinate animals on the other side. And while I was doing this, the dominant animal in the group, who was male named Ozzie, eventually ran away and came back and tried to give me a piece of monkey jack, which is, is literally made by Purina. I mean, it looks like dog chow. And so it's not particularly valuable. But he pushed it through the fence at me. And I didn't give him a peanut. He ran back inside to the indoor part of their enclosure, got a, they just got in their fruit and vegetable tray. And so he got the peel of a navel orange. And he brought that out and did the same thing.
两只手都拿着花生，试图引诱占优势的动物到一边，同时偷偷地把花生塞给另一边处于从属地位的动物。就在我这样做的时候，群体中那只占优势的雄性猴子，名叫奥兹，最终跑开了，又回来试图给我一块猴子饼干，那真的是普瑞纳公司生产的。我的意思是，它看起来就像狗粮。所以它并不是特别有价值。但他把它从栅栏里推给我。我没有给他花生。他跑回围栏的室内部分，拿到了他们刚收到的水果和蔬菜盘。于是他拿到了一个脐橙皮。他把它带出来，做了同样的事情。
And when I didn't give him a peanut, eventually he went back inside and came out with a whole quarter of a navel orange. And he brought that to me and he pushed it through the fence and dropped at my feet. And I did give him the peanut. But it got me to thinking because I was fairly certain that if I had walked up to Ozzy and offered him a peanut versus a quarter of a naval orange, he would have taken the orange. So why was it that all of a sudden he wanted the peanut? Well, there are lots of possibilities, but one of them is that he wanted the peanut because that's what everybody else was getting. And so I decided to test that. And at the time, I was doing a dissertation looking at how primates perceived value. So it was relatively straightforward to add a condition where we looked at how their response to an outcome changed depending on what the monkey next to them was getting.
当我还是没给他花生时，他最终回到室内，拿出了整整四分之一个脐橙。他把它带给我，从栅栏里推出来，扔在我的脚下。我确实给了他花生。但这让我开始思考，因为我相当确定，如果我走到奥兹面前，给他一个花生和一个四分之一个脐橙，他会选择橙子。那么为什么他突然想要花生了呢？嗯，有很多可能性，但其中之一是，他想要花生是因为那是其他人都在得到的东西。所以我决定测试一下。当时，我正在做关于灵长类动物如何感知价值的论文研究。因此，增加一个条件来观察它们对结果的反应如何根据旁边的猴子得到的东西而改变，是相对直接的。
So probably your most famous study, which followed that encounter and is about 20 years old now, looked at how monkeys responded when given an inferior treat when compared to their partner. Can you tell me about that study and what you found? Well, that was in fact the study we did after I saw Ozzy. So we had two monkeys from the same social group. So all of our monkeys live in social groups with individuals that they grew up with. So they have nice normal social interactions. So we took two monkeys from the same social group. They came inside to their test chamber, and they had to do a really simple task. It was trading a token, and they got a food reward when they did that.
那么，你最著名的研究可能就是在那次遭遇之后进行的，距今已有20年了，它观察了猴子在得到比同伴差的奖励时会有什么反应。你能告诉我关于那个研究以及你的发现吗？嗯，那确实是我在看到奥兹之后做的研究。我们有两只来自同一个社会群体的猴子。我们所有的猴子都生活在它们从小一起长大的社会群体中。所以它们有正常的社会互动。我们从同一个社会群体中取出两只猴子。它们进入测试室，必须完成一项非常简单的任务。就是交换一个代币，完成后它们会得到食物奖励。
And in this case, one of them traded a token. and got something they really liked, which was a grape. Generally speaking, the more expensive it is at the grocery store, the better they like it. The other one traded and got something that they liked less well, which in this case was a piece of cucumber. Now, the thing is, they normally like cucumbers just fine. So we compared that to a control where both of them were trading and getting a cucumber. And they were more than happy to eat those cucumber pieces when both they and their partner were getting a cucumber and in another control where we controlled to see what happened if the grapes were visible, but no one was getting them. So that control was actually
在这种情况下，其中一只交换了代币，得到了它们非常喜欢的东西，也就是葡萄。一般来说，在杂货店里越贵的东西，它们越喜欢。另一只交换后得到了它们不太喜欢的东西，在这种情况下是一块黄瓜。问题是，它们通常很喜欢吃黄瓜。所以我们将此与一个对照组进行了比较，在对照组中，它们两个都在交换并得到黄瓜。当它们和同伴都得到黄瓜时，它们非常乐意吃掉那些黄瓜片。在另一个对照组中，我们控制了如果葡萄可见但没人得到会发生什么。所以那个对照组实际上
particularly mean we would wave the grapes in front of their faces until they gestured towards it. And then when they gestured, we would put the grape down and we would give them the cucumber. But importantly, we did the same thing for both monkeys. So they both ended up getting the cucumber. And in both cases, they accepted and ate their cucumbers most of the time. Whereas when their partner got a grape, they were much more likely to refuse their cucumber, which suggests that they aren't as enthusiastic about those cucumbers when their partner is getting something better. And the video that goes along with that experiment is pretty funny where one of the capuchins is throwing the cucumber at the experimenter. Yeah, that's a female named Lance who actually lives at San Diego Zoo now.
特别刻薄，我们会把葡萄在它们面前晃来晃去，直到它们向葡萄示意。然后当它们示意时，我们会放下葡萄，给它们黄瓜。但重要的是，我们对两只猴子做了同样的事情。所以它们最终都得到了黄瓜。在两种情况下，它们大部分时间都接受并吃掉了黄瓜。然而，当它们的同伴得到葡萄时，它们更有可能拒绝自己的黄瓜，这表明当同伴得到更好的东西时，它们对黄瓜的热情就不那么高了。那个实验附带的视频非常有趣，其中一只卷尾猴把黄瓜扔向了实验者。是的，那是一只名叫兰斯的雌性猴子，她现在住在圣地亚哥动物园。
In full disclosure, she is the only monkey who can do aimed overhand throwing. But that was a pretty common outcome. They would push the rewards back out, they would knock them out of our hand, or they would just turn around and ignore them all together. So let's talk more broadly about why this research is important. I mentioned in my introduction that one of the tenets of your work is that studies like these on how animals react to inequality can help us understand human behavior. What can we learn from studying non-human animals about why humans care so much about fairness? Well, a critical question when we're talking about humans is what is it about, fairness that makes us care. Is it a cultural trait? Is it a biological trait? And I don't mean it's one or the
坦白说，她是唯一能进行瞄准过顶投掷的猴子。但这是一种相当普遍的结果。它们会把奖励推出来，把它们从我们手中打掉，或者干脆转过身去完全无视它们。那么，让我们更广泛地谈谈为什么这项研究很重要。我在介绍中提到，你工作的一个原则是，像这样关于动物如何对不平等做出反应的研究可以帮助我们理解人类行为。通过研究非人类动物，我们能学到什么关于人类为何如此看重公平的原因？嗯，当我们谈论人类时，一个关键问题是，公平的什么特质让我们如此在意。这是一种文化特质吗？还是一种生物学特质？我并不是说它是
other. Obviously, what we consider fair, what actual factors are fair is influenced by our culture. But at core, is it entirely cultural or is there a biological component? And that makes a difference because if there is a biological foundation to it, it makes a difference in when you might expect to see responses, how you might handle situations in which individuals respond to inequity. And, of course, it also helps us to understand the situations in which you might expect to see people respond. So, for instance, why did a sense of fairness evolved if it did evolve? What were the selective pressures? What were the context in which it evolved? Which would tell you something about when you would expect to see people respond the most strongly to unfair situations.
非此即彼。显然，我们认为什么是公平的，什么实际因素是公平的，受到我们文化的影响。但从核心来看，它是完全文化性的，还是存在生物学成分？这很重要，因为如果它有生物学基础，那么在你预期何时会看到反应，以及你如何处理个体对不平等做出反应的情况时，就会有所不同。当然，这也帮助我们理解在什么情况下你会预期看到人们做出反应。所以，例如，如果公平感确实演化了，那么它是如何演化的？选择压力是什么？它在什么背景下演化？这将告诉你关于何时你会预期看到人们对不公平情况做出最强烈反应的信息。
You can't completely get rid of unfairness. There are always going to be situations. where at least in the immediate sense, things are not completely equal. So understanding how we evolve the sense of inequity would help us understand how to ameliorate those situations and how to best approach it so that we can make things the most fair possible for everyone. I'd also like to ask you why it's important to study animals to better understand humans. Animal research is seen as controversial by some, but I also understand that the animals you work with are treated humanely and that they're not forced to do anything.
你无法完全消除不公平。总会有一些情况，至少在直接意义上，事情并不完全平等。因此，理解我们是如何演化出不平等感的，将有助于我们理解如何改善这些情况，以及如何以最佳方式处理它，以便我们能为每个人创造尽可能公平的环境。我还想问你，为什么研究动物对更好地理解人类很重要。动物研究被一些人视为有争议，但我同时也了解到，你合作的动物受到了人道的对待，而且它们没有被强迫做任何事情。
anything. Is that correct? Yeah, our monkeys only participate voluntarily. So they live in a social group and they are never deprived of anything to encourage them to participate. So they get the same food, the same treats, the same access to the outdoors, the same access to their partners, regardless of whether or not they participate in the day's testing. And I think that's really important. It's important ethically, but it's also important for my research. I study social behavior. I want to know what they do naturally. So if we compel them to participate in the studies, then we're not getting natural social behavior. So we want them to participate because they choose to. Our guys live in big outdoor enclosures and social groups. Most of them choose to come in and test most
任何事情。这是正确的吗？是的，我们的猴子只自愿参与。它们生活在一个社会群体中，绝不会被剥夺任何东西来鼓励它们参与。所以无论它们是否参加当天的测试，它们都能得到同样的食物、同样的零食、同样的户外活动机会，以及同样的与同伴接触的机会。我认为这非常重要。这在伦理上很重要，对我的研究也很重要。我研究社会行为。我想知道它们自然会做什么。所以如果我们强迫它们参与研究，我们就无法获得自然的社会行为。所以我们希望它们因为选择而参与。我们的猴子生活在大型户外围栏和社会群体中。它们大多数选择进来测试
of the time. Some days they don't. So if it's the first really nice day after a lot of rain, they're not coming in. There's just not much we can do about that. But we never restrict them from outdoor access or from their social partners. They get the same fruits and vegetables and treats regardless of whether they come in. So that does, and I get this question some too, and that does bias our data set. So for instance, one of the questions that we are really interested in is how relationship quality influences these results. And it's really difficult to test because we know from our studies, and I've published this, that the individuals who are coming in to test in these dietic studies are the ones who have good relationship quality.
大部分时间。有些日子它们不来。所以如果这是下雨后第一个真正美好的日子，它们就不会进来。对此我们无能为力。但我们从不限制它们进入户外或接触社会同伴。无论它们是否进来，它们都能得到同样的水果、蔬菜和零食。所以这确实——我也经常被问到这个问题——这确实使我们的数据集产生了偏差。例如，我们非常感兴趣的问题之一是关系质量如何影响这些结果。这很难测试，因为我们从研究中知道，而且我已经发表过相关文章，那些参与这些二元研究的个体是那些关系质量良好的个体。
They're the ones who are spending time together and grooming one another in their social group. We're not getting the ones who don't spend time together. They won't come in together. So it's really difficult to test how relationship quality is influencing these behaviors we're interested in, like inequity responses and cooperation, because we can't get the ones who don't have good relationship quality. So one of the things that we try to do, too, is after we do the more controlled tests at the diatic level, we also do tests at the entire group level, which lack a lot of the things. of experimental control. I can't control the number of trials for session. I can't control who
它们是在社会群体中花时间在一起并互相梳理毛发的个体。我们无法获得那些不花时间在一起的个体。它们不会一起进来。所以很难测试关系质量如何影响我们感兴趣的这些行为，比如不平等反应和合作，因为我们无法获得那些关系质量不好的个体。所以我们尝试做的另一件事是，在进行更受控的二元水平测试后，我们也会在整个群体水平上进行测试，这缺乏很多实验控制。我无法控制每场试验的次数。我无法控制谁
comes up. I can't control the order in which they participate. But when you've got something set up for the entire social group, say for an hour, an hour and a half, almost every pair is going to participate sooner or later. So we can start to get some data from these other diads. And of course, the frequency with which they participate together tells you a lot. Now, as humans, we definitely care when we get less than someone else. But we also sometimes feel uncomfortable when we we come out on top in a situation where we get more than someone else. Do any non-human animals react that way as well? They do, actually. Not nearly as strongly as they do to getting less. But then again, neither do humans, according to a lot of the research. So maybe that's not such a
会过来。我无法控制它们参与的顺序。但当你为整个社会群体设置了一些东西，比如一个小时或一个半小时，几乎每一对都会迟早参与。所以我们可以开始从这些其他二元组中获得一些数据。当然，它们一起参与的频率说明了很多问题。现在，作为人类，当我们得到比别人少的东西时，我们肯定会在意。但当我们处于优势地位，得到比别人多的时候，我们有时也会感到不舒服。有没有非人类动物也会那样反应？它们确实会，实际上。虽然不像得到较少时反应那么强烈。但话说回来，根据许多研究，人类也不是那样。所以也许这并不那么
surprise. Chimpanzees actually, when chimpanzees get a grape and their partner gets a cucumber, they are more likely to refuse that grape if their partner gets a cucumber as compared to when their partner also got a grape. So it's statistically significant, but it also seems to be biologically relevant. There is a difference there, I think, just because something significant doesn't necessarily mean that it's a large enough effect to mean anything. However, it is a much smaller effect than their response when they get less than a partner. But there's some really good data out there suggesting that the same is true with humans.
令人惊讶。黑猩猩实际上，当黑猩猩得到葡萄而它们的同伴得到黄瓜时，如果它们的同伴也得到了葡萄，它们更有可能拒绝那颗葡萄。所以这在统计学上是显著的，但它似乎也具有生物学相关性。我认为这里存在差异，仅仅因为某事是显著的并不一定意味着它的影响大到足以意味着什么。然而，这比它们在得到比同伴少时的反应要小得多。但有一些非常好的数据表明，人类也是如此。
Peter Blake and Katie McCallick have a lovely study. It's a cross-cultural study on kids from seven different cultures. And kids from most cultures, all the cultures, they studied, respond negatively when they get less than a partner. And the responses increase across age. It was a cross-sectional study, but the responses became stronger across age. But only kids from a few societies responded when they got more than a partner, and they weren't as strong of a magnitude as the ones when they got less. Evolutionarily, what might be the benefit to that kind of behavior? There actually is a benefit. It's just a little bit further removed. So the obvious benefit to responding to inequity when you get less is that it tells you something about the value of your partner.
彼得·布莱克和凯蒂·麦卡利克有一项很棒的研究。这是一项关于来自七种不同文化的儿童的跨文化研究。来自大多数文化，即他们研究的所有文化中的儿童，在得到比同伴少时都会做出负面反应。而且反应随着年龄的增长而增加。这是一项横断面研究，但反应随着年龄的增长变得更强烈。但只有来自少数社会的儿童在得到比同伴多时做出了反应，而且它们的强度不如得到较少时那么大。从演化角度来看，这种行为可能有什么好处？实际上确实有一个好处。只是稍微远了一点。所以对得到较少时对不平等做出反应的明显好处是，它告诉你关于你同伴价值的一些信息。
This was proposed several decades ago by economists and psychologists roughly the same time. The idea being that if you have a sense of inequity, it allows you to judge the value of your partner. So essentially a sense of fairness or a sense of inequity is a partner choice mechanism. If you're working with someone, a partner choice mechanism in cooperation. So if you're working with someone and they are constantly taking more than their fair share of the rewards after a cooperative interaction, it's time to go find someone new. Just sampling the environment, you're likely to find someone who treat you better than that individual. And if that is the case, then I would actually expect that responses to inequity will be widespread. And so far,
这是几十年前由经济学家和心理学家在大致相同的时间提出的。其观点是，如果你有一种不平等感，它允许你判断你同伴的价值。所以本质上，公平感或不平等感是一种同伴选择机制。如果你和某人一起工作，这是一种合作中的同伴选择机制。所以如果你和某人一起工作，而他们在合作互动后总是拿走比他们应得份额更多的奖励，那么是时候去找一个新的人了。只要对环境进行采样，你很可能会找到一个比那个人对待你更好的人。如果情况确实如此，那么我实际上会预期对不平等的反应将是广泛存在的。到目前为止，
that's what we found. Most cooperative species seem to show some evidence of inequity. Advantageous inequity is a bit further removed, but I think also important, the difference is between helping you identify good partners and helping you cultivate and maintain a good partner. So if you and I are working together, and let's say by chance, not because I'm being a jerk in this case, I keep getting more than you. If I recognize that you're sooner or later going to get frustrated and go find a new partner and I value our relationship, I should do something about it. So if I can recognize that the fact that I'm getting more than you is putting our relationship at peril in peril, then I can do something about that. I can give you some. I can help you out.
这就是我们所发现的。大多数合作物种似乎都表现出一些不平等的证据。优势不平等稍微远了一点，但我认为也很重要，区别在于帮助你识别好的同伴和帮助你培养及维持一个好的同伴。所以如果你和我一起工作，假设偶然地，不是因为我在这件事上是个混蛋，我一直得到比你多。如果我意识到你迟早会感到沮丧并去找一个新的同伴，而我重视我们的关系，我就应该对此做点什么。所以如果我能认识到我得到比你多这一事实正在使我们的关系处于危险之中，那么我就能对此做点什么。我可以给你一些。我可以帮助你。
I can refuse my rewards. I can do something to rectify the inequity. And by paying a short-term cost to rectify that inequity, I can maintain the long-term benefit of our cooperative relationship. And if I do it right, then we maintain this relationship that has been beneficial in the past and presumably will be so in the future. So for long-lived species that have consistent cooperative interactions over a very long period of time, it makes a lot of sense. Now, you study mainly primates, but these questions have been studied in other species as well. What are some of the other animals that researchers have studied? and what have they found?
我可以拒绝我的奖励。我可以做些什么来纠正这种不公平。通过支付短期成本来纠正这种不公平，我可以维持我们合作关系的长期利益。如果我做得对，我们就能维持这种过去一直有益、未来想必也会有益的关系。因此，对于那些在很长一段时间内保持持续合作互动的长寿物种来说，这是非常有意义的。现在，你主要研究灵长类动物，但这些问题在其他物种中也得到了研究。研究人员还研究了哪些其他动物？他们发现了什么？
Like, do dogs and cats notice unfairness or birds or fish? I understand you've looked at fish. I mean, how can you tell when fish feel that they're being treated unfairly? Well, the same way that you look at primate. You see whether they take the third. Actually, I'm going to digress for just the second. That's an interesting point. You ask how we know if they feel like they're treated unfairly.
比如，狗、猫、鸟或鱼会注意到不公平吗？我知道你研究过鱼。我的意思是，你怎么能判断鱼是否感到自己受到了不公平的对待？嗯，就像观察灵长类动物一样。你看它们是否接受第三种选择。其实，我要稍微离题一下。这是一个有趣的点。你问我们怎么知道它们是否觉得受到了不公平的对待。
We don't. We know if they respond behaviorally. So one of the interesting points is we can test right now whether they are responding to an equity by refusing a food reward, which is a very costly response. We don't know if they notice. We don't know if they care. There is a difference there. One of the things that we and others are hoping to do is use some of the new non-invasive
我们不知道。我们只知道它们是否有行为上的反应。所以有趣的一点是，我们现在可以测试它们是否通过拒绝食物奖励来对不公平做出反应，这是一种代价高昂的反应。我们不知道它们是否注意到了。我们不知道它们是否在乎。这之间是有区别的。我们和其他人希望做的事情之一是使用一些新的非侵入性技术，
technologies like eye tracking, thermal imaging, where you can look at changes in affect, so emotional state, by looking at changes in facial temperature. even short-term changes in hormones and so forth, to see whether or not they are potentially noticing some of these inequitable outcomes, even if they don't refuse their reward. There is some really good evidence in Capuchans that if rewards are too good, they won't refuse them even if they're very unequal. So maybe they do feel inequity, and we just don't have any way of telling. But anyway, back to your previous question about what other species respond.
比如眼动追踪、热成像，你可以通过观察面部温度的变化来观察情感（即情绪状态）的变化。甚至包括短期内的荷尔蒙变化等等，来看看它们是否可能注意到了这些不公平的结果，即使它们没有拒绝奖励。在卷尾猴身上有一些非常好的证据表明，如果奖励太好，即使它们非常不平等，它们也不会拒绝。所以也许它们确实感受到了不公平，只是我们没有办法判断。但无论如何，回到你之前关于其他物种如何反应的问题。
So there's lots of work in dogs and wolves. A lot of it's been done by Frida Ranga and her colleagues in Austria. There's also some work by Alexander Horowitz and several other labs. And not surprisingly, given how cooperative they are, dogs and wolves seem to respond. And there's also some really nice evidence that they are changing their behavior. So not only are they refusing the outcomes, but they're also changing their behavior towards both the experimenter and the other dog, refusing to come up and interact with them as much, avoiding them and so forth. There's also some work in some of the corvids. So these are crows and ravens and so forth.
在狗和狼身上有很多研究。其中很多是由奥地利的弗里达·兰加（Frida Ranga）和她的同事完成的。亚历山大·霍洛维茨（Alexander Horowitz）和其他几个实验室也做了一些工作。不出所料，考虑到它们有多么合作，狗和狼似乎会做出反应。而且还有一些非常好的证据表明它们正在改变自己的行为。所以它们不仅拒绝了结果，而且还改变了对实验者和另一只狗的行为，拒绝走过来与它们互动，避开它们等等。在一些鸦科动物身上也有一些研究。也就是乌鸦、渡鸦等等。
Ravens also respond to inequity. There is no, we did not find it in the fish. We tested cleaner fish. This is actually Katie McAuliffe and Redwin Fashari led this. I was part of the group that they were the ones who led it. They tested cleaner fish who are highly cooperative. And so you might expect to see it there. They did not respond negative.
渡鸦也会对不公平做出反应。不，我们在鱼身上没有发现这一点。我们测试了清洁鱼。这实际上是由凯蒂·麦考利夫（Katie McAuliffe）和雷德温·法沙里（Redwin Fashari）领导的。我是该小组的一员，但他们是领导者。他们测试了高度合作的清洁鱼。所以你可能会期望在那里看到它。它们没有做出负面反应。
But the interesting thing is cleaner fish are highly interdependent, and we don't see it in the interdependent primate species either. So these would be the cooperative breeders like marmosets and tamarins and the bi-ferential care species like owl monkeys. Within a breeding pair, they don't respond negatively in these tasks. And it may be that if you are already in an interdependent relationship, a little bit of inequity is not enough to make you break up the partnership and go find a new one. So they may be more sensitive to inequity from the partnership is being formed, but not so sensitive to inequity once you're in it, because it's just too costly. Well, talking again about humans, there is a lot of individual variation. Some people are far more sensitive to unfairness and injustice than other people are. Do you see that individual variation in non-human primates? We do. And we haven't really been able to explain what is driving it, partially because of sample size issues. Non-human primates are hard to study. especially if you need a large intact social group that has been together for a long time. So when we run studies with sample sizes of 16, it's considered huge.
但有趣的是，清洁鱼是高度相互依赖的，我们在相互依赖的灵长类物种中也没有看到这一点。这些物种包括像狨猴和柽柳猴这样的合作繁殖者，以及像夜猴这样的双亲抚育物种。在繁殖对内，它们在这些任务中不会做出负面反应。这可能是因为如果你已经处于一种相互依赖的关系中，一点点不公平不足以让你破坏这种伙伴关系并去寻找新的伙伴。所以它们可能在伙伴关系形成时对不公平更敏感，但一旦进入关系中就不那么敏感了，因为代价太大了。嗯，再谈谈人类，个体差异很大。有些人比其他人对不公平和不公正敏感得多。你在非人类灵长类动物中看到这种个体差异吗？我们看到了。我们还没有真正能够解释是什么驱动了它，部分原因是样本量的问题。非人类灵长类动物很难研究。特别是如果你需要一个在一起很长时间的大型完整社会群体。所以当我们进行样本量为16的研究时，这被认为是巨大的。
But with humans, of course, you want sample sizes in the hundreds. So it's really difficult. We can document individual variability. It's really difficult to statistically demonstrate what's going on. What we can say is that we tend to see more variability in the apes than we do in the monkeys. Now, that is not a statistical statement. that is a Sarah thinks this is what's going on statement. But I'm not necessarily surprised.
但对于人类，当然，你希望样本量达到数百。所以这真的很难。我们可以记录个体差异。在统计学上证明发生了什么非常困难。我们可以说的是，我们倾向于在类人猿身上看到比在猴子身上更多的变异性。现在，这不是一个统计陈述，这是“莎拉认为发生了什么”的陈述。但我并不感到惊讶。
I think that for the monkeys, this may be, my hypothesis is that this may be more of an evolved response and it's just a response pattern that you see when you get treated unfairly X number of times, it's time to react. Whereas the chimpanzees may be showing more flexibility of response. So they may be able to better take into account the context
我认为对于猴子来说，我的假设是这可能更多是一种进化的反应，这只是当你被不公平对待X次时所看到的反应模式，是时候做出反应了。而黑猩猩可能表现出更灵活的反应。所以它们可能能够更好地考虑到环境
and what's going on. What we do know is that there are impacts of dominance, so more dominant individuals are more upset by inequity than more subordinates, which is not surprising. From an evolutionary perspective, you'd expect that because more dominant individuals have more to lose, because getting treated inequitably might mean that they're about to get challenged for their rank. From a mechanistic perspective, they're used to getting better outcome than the subordinates. So they probably are less used to being treated unfairly and therefore more likely to respond when they are. We don't see a consistent sex difference. Some studies have found that males were more responsive to inequity. Some studies have found that females were. So I don't actually think there's a consistent sex difference.
以及正在发生的事情。我们所知道的是，支配地位有影响，所以更占优势的个体比从属个体对不公平更感到不安，这并不奇怪。从进化的角度来看，你会预料到这一点，因为更占优势的个体有更多的东西要失去，因为被不公平对待可能意味着它们即将面临等级挑战。从机制的角度来看，它们习惯于比从属个体获得更好的结果。所以它们可能不太习惯被不公平对待，因此当它们被不公平对待时，更有可能做出反应。我们没有看到一致的性别差异。一些研究发现雄性对不公平更敏感。一些研究发现雌性更敏感。所以我实际上认为没有一致的性别差异。
We do tend to see a personality difference, at least in chimpanzees, we, in a four chimpanzees, very large study, found that chimps that were higher on more social personality dimensions, extraversion and sociability. So in other words, they were more likely to spend time. with other chimpanzees were more likely to respond negatively to inequity, whereas those that were higher on dimensions that were more human-oriented were actually more likely to respond negatively when in that contrast condition I mentioned where we waved the grape in front of them and then gave them the cucumber, which may suggest that they thought that the human was cheating them and didn't like that. We don't know, but that's a reasonable hypothesis. And I still think there's something
我们确实倾向于看到人格差异，至少在黑猩猩身上，我们在一个针对四只黑猩猩的大型研究中发现，在更多社交人格维度（外向性和社交性）上得分更高的黑猩猩，换句话说，它们更有可能花时间与其他黑猩猩在一起，更有可能对不公平做出负面反应，而那些在更偏向人类的维度上得分更高的黑猩猩，实际上更有可能在对比条件下做出负面反应，即我提到的那种我们在它们面前挥舞葡萄然后给它们黄瓜的情况，这可能表明它们认为人类在欺骗它们，并且不喜欢这样。我们不知道，但这是一个合理的假设。而且我仍然认为有一些
going on with relationship quality. But we haven't been able to get at that because, as I alluded to earlier, the tests that we ran to look at that. What ended up happening was we only got individuals with good relationships in the first place who were willing to come in and test together. So, I don't have an answer. But doesn't that happen with human subjects as well? I mean, you know, the people who tend to want to participate in studies are a lot like the, you know, apes and monkeys you're testing, right? Yep. And most of the human studies are either individuals who are being brought, who they say bring a friend to the lab, or they're complete strangers. So you're not getting that middle ground where you have individuals
关于关系质量的事情。但我们无法弄清楚这一点，因为正如我之前提到的，我们用来观察这一点的测试。最终发生的情况是，我们只得到了那些本身关系良好且愿意进来一起测试的个体。所以，我没有答案。但这在人类受试者身上也会发生吗？我的意思是，你知道，那些倾向于想要参与研究的人很像你正在测试的类人猿和猴子，对吧？是的。而且大多数人类研究要么是那些被带过来的人，他们说带个朋友到实验室，要么是完全的陌生人。所以你没有得到那种中间地带，即你有彼此认识但关系质量不同的个体。
who know each other but have differing relationship qualities. You can get around that by going in and testing a daycare center or people in a fraternity or sorority or something. But yes, you're absolutely right. How do you keep from anthropomorphizing these animals you're working with them? And clearly you work with them for long periods of time and you really get to know them And you're talking about their personalities and, you know, testing them on the big five, for example. Yeah, you really don't. I mean, not to be blunt, but you don't. So, for instance, the capuchin monkeys live, our longest live capuchin lived 55 years.
你可以通过去幼儿园、兄弟会或姐妹会测试人们来绕过这个问题。但是的，你是绝对正确的。你如何防止将你一起工作的这些动物拟人化？显然你和它们一起工作了很长时间，你真的了解它们，而且你在谈论它们的个性，比如用“大五人格”测试它们。是的，你真的做不到。我的意思是，不是为了直率，但你做不到。例如，卷尾猴的寿命，我们寿命最长的卷尾猴活了55岁。
I've been working with literally the same capuchin monkeys for 23 years now, 24 years now. It's been 24. And this chimps the same amount of time. So you don't. We know them quite well. And what we do is keep in mind that we're being anthropomorphic, that we're going to be anthropomorphic. We're almost not going to have a choice and try to use it appropriately. So when we do these studies, we try very hard to only talk about the actual experimental data.
我现在实际上已经和同样的卷尾猴一起工作了23年，现在是24年了。已经24年了。黑猩猩也是同样的时间。所以你做不到。我们非常了解它们。我们所做的是记住我们正在进行拟人化，我们将会进行拟人化。我们几乎别无选择，只能尝试适当地使用它。所以当我们做这些研究时，我们非常努力地只谈论实际的实验数据。
We run these studies with people as much as possible. We try to do it in a way that is non-biased. If we can, we run it on a computerized platform so that you don't have a human, being in there. If you can't, you record it and you do what you can. So for instance, in a trading task, you might have a platform in front of you where you have marked where your hand goes and everything is as marked as possible. And then you have every bit of data double-coded by another observer who doesn't know what the hypotheses are and who preferably doesn't care. Someone who it's not their dissertation, it's not their grant, it's not their whatever.
我们尽可能多地用人来运行这些研究。我们尝试以一种无偏见的方式来做。如果可以的话，我们在计算机平台上运行它，这样你就不会有人类在里面。如果不能，你就记录下来，尽你所能。例如，在交易任务中，你面前可能有一个平台，上面标记了你的手放在哪里，一切都尽可能地标记清楚。然后你让另一位观察者对每一位数据进行双重编码，他不知道假设是什么，而且最好不在乎。不是他们的论文，不是他们的资助，不是他们的任何东西。
So we call this inter-observer reliability. And that helps. It doesn't make it perfect, but it helps. And we have to remember that we, as I mentioned earlier, we were talking about what the animals do, not what the animals think, feel, what their motivations are. I think that's a really important distinction. One that we actually don't remember enough in humans either. We tend to extrapolate from what the humans did on the study to what their motivations were because we are humans. and I don't think that's a fair assessment with humans either.
所以我们称之为观察者间信度。这有帮助。它不能使其完美，但有帮助。我们必须记住，正如我之前提到的，我们谈论的是动物做什么，而不是动物想什么、感觉什么、它们的动机是什么。我认为这是一个非常重要的区别。我们在人类身上也没有足够记住这一点。我们倾向于从人类在研究中所做的事情推断出他们的动机，因为我们是人类。而且我认为这对人类来说也不是一个公平的评估。
But that's a whole other podcast. But the other thing is I think anthropomorphism can be very useful. So, for instance, back to that initial story about Ozzy, I watched what Ozzy was doing, bringing me oranges for peanuts and thought, huh, if we were humans, we would think that that might be inequity. How could we test that? So there's nothing wrong with making an assessment about what you think of an animal is doing, as long as you then use that as the starting point for hypothesis testing with a nice,
但这又是另一个播客的话题了。但另一件事是，我认为拟人化可能非常有用。例如，回到关于奥兹（Ozzy）的那个最初的故事，我观察奥兹在做什么，用花生换取我给它的橙子，心想，嗯，如果我们是人类，我们会认为这可能是不公平。我们该如何测试这一点？所以，对你认为动物正在做的事情做出评估并没有错，只要你随后将其作为假设测试的起点，并进行一个好的、
tight experimental test rather than just going with it and not bothering to test what you see. So it can be extremely useful as that starting point and helping you get some insight into what they're doing, especially after a couple of decades of watching them. You still, I still see things where I didn't notice something before and think, I wonder what's going on there. Well, let's talk for a moment about some other research. search that you have done, your work with the endowment effect, which is something that causes people to consider an item that they've just come to possess as higher in value than the maximum
严谨的实验测试，而不是仅仅随波逐流而不去测试你所看到的东西。因此，作为起点，它可以极其有用，并帮助你深入了解它们正在做什么，特别是在观察了它们几十年之后。我仍然会看到一些我以前没有注意到的事情，并想，我想知道那里发生了什么。好吧，让我们谈谈你做过的其他研究，你关于禀赋效应的工作，这是一种导致人们认为他们刚刚拥有的物品价值高于他们几分钟前为获得它而支付的最高价格的现象。
price they would have paid to acquire it just moments before. And this is something I understand you've studied in both humans and chimpanzees. Can you talk about those studies? Yeah. The endowment effect is a lot of fun. It's something I've done with a number of colleagues, Owen Jones at Vanderbilt, being one of the primary ones I've worked with on this. And that definition is a mouthful. But essentially, the endowment effect is the idea that when you have something, once you come to possess something, you suddenly value it more than you did a moment before. And importantly, it's not due to learning new information about it that makes it more valuable. And it's not due to any sort of sentimental attachment. It's not because suddenly it was the thing you had with you
这是我理解的你在人类和黑猩猩身上都研究过的东西。你能谈谈这些研究吗？是的。禀赋效应非常有趣。这是我和许多同事一起做的事情，范德比尔特大学的欧文·琼斯（Owen Jones）是我在这方面合作的主要人员之一。那个定义很拗口。但本质上，禀赋效应是这样一种观点：当你拥有某样东西时，一旦你拥有了某样东西，你突然会比刚才更看重它。重要的是，这并不是因为了解了关于它的新信息而使其更有价值。也不是因为任何形式的情感依恋。不是因为突然间它是你在孩子上大学前最后一次徒步旅行时带在身边的东西，
on your last hike with your kid before they went off to college or something. It's It's just because you possess it. And there have been hundreds of studies that have shown that humans do this. You ask them how much they're willing to pay to buy the book. And then a minute later, you ask them how much they're willing to sell the book for, and it's more. And so there has been a lot of research into why people would do this and lots of hypothesizing. Maybe it's related to loss aversion, but of course, that's kind of circular because if it's related to loss of version, then why are people showing the loss ofversion in the first place? perhaps people just want to make a profit.
或者类似的事情。仅仅是因为你拥有它。已经有数百项研究表明人类会这样做。你问他们愿意花多少钱买这本书。然后一分钟后，你问他们愿意以多少钱卖掉这本书，结果更高。因此，关于人们为什么会这样做进行了大量的研究，并进行了大量的假设。也许它与损失厌恶有关，但当然，这有点循环论证，因为如果它与损失厌恶有关，那么为什么人们首先表现出损失厌恶？也许人们只是想获利。
And that is true, but in some of these cases, the amount people won't sell it for is a huge profit. Dan Ariely famously has a study with Duke basketball tickets where people could have made an enormous profit and chose not to. So that doesn't make a whole lot of sense either. And so there are lots of explanations that aren't satisfying because they don't make a predictable, they don't explain it in a predictable way. And our hypothesis was that, like, as has been proposed for a number of, of other cognitive biases, it probably made sense in the evolutionary past that if you had something, you hung on to it because you didn't know the value of what you would potentially be trading for,
这是真的，但在某些情况下，人们不愿出售的价格是巨大的利润。丹·艾瑞里（Dan Ariely）有一个关于杜克大学篮球门票的著名研究，人们本可以获得巨大的利润，但选择了不卖。所以这也没有多大意义。因此，有很多解释并不令人满意，因为它们没有做出可预测的解释，它们没有以可预测的方式解释它。我们的假设是，就像已经为许多其他认知偏差所提出的那样，它在进化史上可能是有意义的，如果你有某样东西，你就紧紧抓住它，因为你不知道你可能要交易的东西的价值，
and you also didn't know if you were actually going to get the other thing. So maybe I hand something to you and then I don't get anything else back. So there should be a bias to hang on to what you've got. There is an expression. A bird in the hand is worth two in the bush. It's true. And so we decided to test that by looking at whether or not other species. had an endowment effect. And there's a famous study by Jack Mitch from years ago where he essentially gave students coffee mugs, had them do a task, and then said, oh, by the way, if you don't want the coffee mug, you can trade it for a chocolate bar. Another class got the reverse. And then one class did the task and then was given a choice between the coffee mug and the chocolate bar.
而且你也不知道你是否真的会得到另一件东西。所以也许我把东西交给你，然后我什么也没得到。所以应该有一种偏见来坚持你所拥有的。有一句谚语。双鸟在林不如一鸟在手。这是真的。所以我们决定通过观察其他物种是否也有禀赋效应来测试这一点。杰克·米奇（Jack Mitch）多年前有一个著名的研究，他基本上给了学生咖啡杯，让他们完成一项任务，然后说，哦，顺便说一句，如果你不想要这个咖啡杯，你可以用它换一块巧克力棒。另一个班级则相反。然后一个班级完成了任务，然后被给予在咖啡杯和巧克力棒之间做出选择。
And the class that got the choice was about 50-50. The class that got the coffee mug, 90% of them kept the mug. The class that got the chocolate bar, 90% of them kept the chocolate bar. So it doesn't make any sense. They should, everybody should be at 50% if the preferences are consistent. So we did that with chimps. And then later with gorillas and orangutans. And around the same time, some other groups started doing similar sorts of things. So another group did it with some other great apes and it's been done with Capuchins.
获得选择权的班级里，大约有一半人选择了交换。而拿到咖啡杯的班级，90%的人留下了杯子。拿到巧克力棒的班级，90%的人留下了巧克力棒。这完全说不通。如果偏好是一致的，每个人都应该有50%的选择比例。所以我们对黑猩猩做了同样的实验，后来又对大猩猩和红毛猩猩做了实验。大约在同一时间，其他研究小组也开始进行类似的实验。另一个小组对其他类人猿进行了实验，卷尾猴也做过同样的测试。
And all of them show strong endowment effects. Once they've got something, they are hanging on to it. And it's not because they won't trade with humans. If you offer them something better, they will happily trade back. And it's not because they think, you know, they aren't just trade. for fun, although they don't show endowment effect for toys, only for food. Oh, interesting. So we then decided to test and see whether or not the endowment effect, from an evolutionary
它们都表现出了强烈的禀赋效应。一旦它们得到了某样东西，就会紧紧抓住不放。这并不是因为它们不愿与人类交易。如果你提供更好的东西，它们会很乐意换回来。而且这也不是因为它们认为……它们不仅仅是为了好玩而交易，尽管它们对玩具没有表现出禀赋效应，只对食物有。
perspective, you should only show an endowment effect for something that matters from an evolutionary perspective, like food. So we tested tools. So we had a dipping tool that they could use to dip in and get some, it was flavored oatmeal. They like flavored oatmeal. And a sponge tool that they could use to get juice. And we tested for an endowment effect between those two tools when the foods were either available or they could see them but couldn't reach them or they just weren't present at all. And they only showed the endowment effect for the tools when they could actually use them, even when they could see the foods but they couldn't reach them. They showed no endowment effect. So it was really sensitive to context, which supports this
从进化的角度来看，你只应该对那些在进化上有意义的东西（比如食物）表现出禀赋效应。所以我们测试了工具。我们有一种蘸取工具，它们可以用它蘸取调味燕麦片——它们喜欢调味燕麦片；还有一种海绵工具，它们可以用它获取果汁。我们测试了当食物可用、可见但无法触及，或者完全不存在时，这两种工具之间是否存在禀赋效应。结果发现，只有在它们能实际使用这些工具时，才会表现出禀赋效应；即使它们能看到食物但无法触及，它们也不会表现出禀赋效应。所以这种效应确实对环境非常敏感，这支持了以下观点：
idea that we evolved this cognitive bias because when something is useful, you should hang on to it because it's useful right now. It's salient in the moment, which supports this idea that a lot of these biases evolved because they were useful. And maybe now they look quirky and unreasonable. But there weren't police forces to come and help you if the person on eBay didn't follow through on their end of the deal back several millennia ago. So you needed to be more careful.
我们进化出这种认知偏差是因为当某样东西有用时，你应该紧紧抓住它，因为它当下就有用。它在当下非常显著。这支持了许多此类偏差是因为有用才进化出来的观点。也许现在它们看起来很古怪且不合理，但在几千年前，如果eBay上的交易对方没有履行承诺，可没有警察来帮你。所以你需要更加小心。
So last question. What are the next big issues you're working on? what are the questions you still want to answer? One of the things I'm really interested in is how this relates to what we see in their more natural environments. So when we are in the lab, we motivate all of their studies with food because just like you take undergrads into the lab and get them to do things for money or class credit, it's a nice fungible resource that we can test them with.
最后一个问题。您接下来要研究的重大课题是什么？还有哪些问题是您想解答的？我非常感兴趣的一点是，这与我们在它们更自然的栖息地中观察到的现象有何关联。当我们在实验室时，我们用食物来激励它们参与所有研究，就像你带本科生进实验室，用金钱或学分让他们做事一样，这是一种我们可以用来测试它们的、很好的可替代资源。
And that's not how they're probably making their decisions in the wild because they don't trade much food in the wild. They trade grooming. They trade social support against other, social support being support against others who are attacking them. Social support is preferred against other groups and so forth. Females are trading aloe maternal care. You're helping each other with their offspring. So one of the things that I've been doing is working with Marcella Benitez, who's faculty at Emory to try and study some of these questions in the wild. So we've got some grants to do testing, cognitive testing, both in the wild and in the lab, to see if we can see, are the monkeys in the wild doing the same things as the monkeys in the lab? And then what might it look like for an
但这可能不是它们在野外做决策的方式，因为它们在野外很少交易食物。它们交易的是梳理毛发，交易的是社会支持——即在面对他人攻击时提供支持。社会支持在对抗其他群体时是首选，等等。雌性之间交易的是异亲照顾，即互相帮助照顾后代。所以我一直在做的一件事是与埃默里大学的教员马塞拉·贝尼特斯合作，试图在野外研究这些问题。我们获得了一些资助，在野外和实验室进行认知测试，看看我们是否能观察到野外的猴子是否与实验室里的猴子表现一致。那么，对于一只
actual wild capuchin to be doing this? And we can do that in two ways. First, we can do observational studies in our own social groups. And then we can also do observational studies on these groups in the wild. So it's not necessarily a new question per se, but trying to understand how we complete this arc to understand what we're seeing in the lab maps on to what we see in natural environments, which I think is really an important question for understanding how it relates to humans. And along with that, we're trying to get at some of the underlying mechanisms. So Marcella and I've started studying hormones. We've now got an eye tracker. There are lots of things you can do non-invasively with the monkeys' full participation in consent or assent.
真正的野生卷尾猴来说，这会是什么样子呢？我们可以通过两种方式做到这一点。首先，我们可以在我们自己的社会群体中进行观察研究。然后，我们也可以对野外的这些群体进行观察研究。所以这不一定是一个全新的问题，而是试图理解我们如何完成这个闭环，以了解我们在实验室中观察到的现象如何映射到自然环境中所见，我认为这对理解它与人类的关联是一个非常重要的问题。与此同时，我们正在试图探究一些潜在的机制。马塞拉和我已经开始研究激素。我们现在有了一个眼动追踪器。在猴子完全参与并给予同意或默许的情况下，有很多非侵入性的事情可以做。
They can't give consent. To look at some of the mechanisms to help understand what they're doing. So we would like to take a lot of these lines of research. I also study cooperation and try and tie these together and look at how relationship quality and ecology and these individual differences are interplaying and deciding these social interactions. We're already seeing big differences. We've got one paper, one of my graduate students is writing up, finding that for a cooperation task, it matters what group you're in. The groups are doing fundamentally different things. We've got five social groups at Georgia State
它们无法给予正式的同意。我们通过观察一些机制来帮助理解它们的行为。所以我们想把这些研究方向结合起来。我也研究合作，并试图将这些联系起来，观察关系质量、生态环境以及这些个体差异是如何相互作用并决定这些社会互动的。我们已经看到了巨大的差异。我们有一篇论文，我的一位研究生正在撰写，发现对于合作任务来说，你所在的群体很重要。不同群体在做着本质上不同的事情。我们在佐治亚州立大学有五个社会群体，
and they look completely different. We would have entirely different papers depending on which group we'd looked at. Well, that's amazing. It really is. And because we have so many groups, we can actually see that in a way that it's very difficult to do other places. Well, that all sounds really exciting. I look forward to reading more of your work and learning more about what you are learning. So thank you for joining me today, Dr. Braslin. Thank you. I really enjoyed it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeatingof psychology.org or on Apple Stitcher or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you hear, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us
它们看起来完全不同。根据我们观察的群体不同，我们可能会写出完全不同的论文。那太神奇了。确实如此。正因为我们有这么多群体，我们实际上能以一种在其他地方很难做到的方式观察到这一点。听起来真的很令人兴奋。我期待阅读您更多的作品，并了解更多您的研究成果。感谢您今天加入我们，布拉斯林博士。谢谢，我很享受这次交流。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至
at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的音效编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的基姆·米尔斯。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。